What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity!
Today we are playing a tournament
with the bottom of the racket.
To five points, 0-0.
Yea, and no two point difference.
What was that!
Sorry!
Look how low he is!
He is really in the position I have never seen that before!
What? He played it like off the side!
I'm sorry Otto!
What can you do...
He's just putting it on
Yeah there we have the smash!
I tried to distract you there!
I don't know what that was
Wait wait!
Look at that!
How is that even possible?
That was the shot of the day!
I knew it!
I never thought that playing with the
butt of the racket could be this intense!
Hahahaha, sorry!
Injury time out for Emil!
We need a medic!
So we had our medical team have a look at it
I got some like eight to ten stitches and now I'm ready.
It came straight to my mind
that I don't want to risk it!
Sensei is back!
It was a good match but a tight match.
You gave everything you got,
even a piece of your skin!
Don't forget to hit subscribe
and watch our previous episodes there!
Until next time!